okay God that going get out of my notes
make sure that there are people that's
always a good thing
come on your dang thing there we go
that's what I'm after
all right greetings of the duck right
off the bat right off the bat my hair is
probably not gonna be as like gorgeously
flow because I literally just got out of
the shower that's why it's like I didn't
like get it cut it's just tucked behind
the ear cuz it's wet I didn't have time
to blow-dry it because yes clam in fact
that vain happy Mardi Gras oh nice thank
you very much okay so let me get my
notes up here I hope everybody's doing
well now that we're into March um just
bump them drinking thank you need a
drink excuse me hurts a little dry okay
so how was my week um it's been alright
um you know went with my daughter to see
how to train your dragon' three over the
weekend that's why I got that review out
that was nice she enjoyed it which is
always good uh but yeah you know back to
the back to the grindstone it's it's
been weird getting uh
out of the habit of having a video every
day like initially I like I almost felt
a moment of panic like looking at the
docket and what I was planning and be
like wait I don't have something like
that needs to be uploaded ready to go in
the morning and that's weird it makes me
feel like I'm screwing this up and like
I should be doing something and I'm not
now that I've actually sort of gotten a
couple of videos ahead and realized oh
I'm now like a week ahead by doing only
three videos it has given me a better
perspective on the amount of time this
is gonna free up and hopefully be able
to result in some more elaborate things
which unfortunately is gonna wait a
little bit and is unlikely to apply to
the Doctor Who stuff cuz the BBC are
jerks and unresponsive jerks is the most
annoying thing it's actually really
frustrating cuz BBC has flagged my stuff
before but the last time that happened
they a didn't block it
they just demonetized
and and we're fairly responsive when I
challenged that so to have them flat-out
block a video just so nobody could even
see it yeah I was irritating so we got
here happy day to everybody
yeah on the plus side you got your sleep
back oh oh you naive fool if you think
this means I get sleep ha ha very
optimistic of you
I hope my comment about the Tenth Doctor
suit wasn't too irritating or nagging
after I uploaded it I thought maybe I
should have vetted it out no it was it
was a it was a fair jab yeah totally
aboveboard I wasn't actually irritated
as well as there's always one of the
problems with the text reply to
something is you're able to read in a
tone of voice that may or may not have
been what I intended so don't don't
worry about it buddy late for me but
here I am well geez knowings the
timezone of some of my folks are you I
imagine this is very light late for some
of you and you'll sleep like that's
gonna happen
yeah spring for Oh God spring forwards
coming up ah shoot oh I hate daylight
savings time it's the stupidest thing I
don't know why why ah okay uh how's your
day been so far not bad fairly
productive actually all things
considered which felt good again that's
one of the things helped me get more on
board with with my revised schedule but
you're the best youtuber just letting
you know Wow
thank you huh I'd sense not something I
would ever claim about myself but I
ain't gonna lie it's nice to hear
somebody else who thinks that so uh
what's your favorite song by Queen prop
it's probably fat bottomed girls
actually they have a lot of really good
stuff that so I do have my list of stuff
gone on since the last time that I feel
is worth addressing so yeah Luke Perry
passed away that was that was sudden I
had heard about his stroke a couple days
before it was only I think fifty-two now
I'd like I didn't really watch a lot of
the stuff that Luke Perry did I actually
think the only things I ever saw him in
were the fifth element which he's only
in the very beginning of and the
original movie Buffy the Vampire Slayer
and that was it I'm pretty sure so like
I don't have any particular deep-seated
affection for him but you know I know it
was part of the new Riverdale which is
now stopped shooting because of his
passing
and I I've known enough people who did
sort of take in the sort of stuff that
he did and sort of felt that loss so
yeah dad that was a little bit of a
bummer yeah this month is Batman's 80th
anniversary
too bad the Gotham finale is an area
until after the anniversary I keep track
of too many fictional character
anniversaries but 80 years yeah yep and
we will never be rid of him which I'm
not sure is a bad thing so there you go
what do you want in series 12 of Doctor
Who
ie I really try very hard to not project
what I would like to happen on the shows
that I watch because I feel like the
more that I indulge in something like
that the more disappointed I'm gonna be
when it's not what I was hoping for so I
don't really don't really do that I want
I want I do want to see changes I do
want to see I want to see Chibnall
appear to be trying to adjust and
correct and refine I don't have a
specific vision for how to do that
it's the 53rd anniversary of the arc
part 1 of course the Doctor Who guide
that insanely specific on a moment's
notice hey there buddy dr. Seuss has his
hundred and 15th birthday on Saturday
whoo boy boy I'm getting up there
because I remember his the big deal when
it was dr. Seuss is hundreth okay um all
right moving on down my list Game of
Thrones Season eight trailer his so this
is like the full proper trailer cuz it
would add like a teaser thing before and
um it's fine I don't think that that
trailer like made me feel anything about
the upcoming season of Game of Thrones
that I wasn't already feeling I didn't
make me more hype today didn't make me
go oh that makes me nervous I'm just
like yep that's Game of Thrones all
right boy howdy
I mean you know other people have more
you know large reactions to that trailer
I didn't really look into it to see if
that was the case another what do you
think about series 11 um series 11 is a
very mixed bag is the short version of
series 11 actually on is it China member
for this this this Sunday's Doctor Who
videos gonna be actually doing a bit of
a deeper dive into series 11
specifically um but if you go back on
the channel I have my overview review
after it finished airing and my thoughts
haven't really changed I'm just gonna
refine and drill into some of them a bit
more um on Sundays video so stick around
for that where's the dr. Seuss biopic um
I actually wonder and and I don't like
honestly don't know he's not a a figure
that I've heard like a bunch of stories
about so I'm not sure of his life and
not to say it's uninteresting I'm not
sure that there's like something about
it that inherently
lends itself to a film narrative because
there's plenty of people with
interesting lives but they were
interesting over such a long period of
time it just doesn't make for a good
movie you kind of need like a central
event to focus things on if you're gonna
make a decent biopic at all I thought
that doesn't not that that actually
stops some of the very not good bio pics
from still happening but yeah what can
you do
unless Doctor Who improves it'll
probably be a long time before we get
another female doctor that's possible I
really hope that isn't the case because
that the the video that I'm putting out
on God I had rested this in a thing of
duct tape and I picked it up in the duct
tape we're still on it um oh somebody
asked where the bottle came from this
came from Saratoga winery in in New York
on New York State not New York State um
but anyway uh so series uh Lebanon and
the whole thing with the female doctor
so the video that's coming out on Sunday
is actually pretty specifically drilling
into what I feel the Proms the series is
I do not feel I'm Jodie Whittaker or the
Companions are the problem despite the
fact that that's the thing most people
are complaining about but they do
unfortunately happen adjacent to the
stuff that actually doesn't work so it
becomes an easy scapegoat and I really
just hope that the actual creators
recognize that that's what's happening
and that that isn't the actual problem
and so that their corrective isn't to
just never have a female doctor again
because that would be hasty and foolish
because reconstructions and audios do
exist do you think you'll ever review
some of the missing first and second
doctor stories yes I do I'll leave it at
that I have a strong urge to reference
council of geeks in the book I'm writing
okay now I have to ask what's the book
because I like my instinct just to be
flattered but that I'm like what's the
book what's the context hold on
huh so I mean part of is paranoia but
I'm also now just genuinely curious a
mystery book you're gonna have somebody
kill me aren't you
dang it ah okay let's see it takes place
in a high school okay so oh best of luck
with that
in any case what else that I have oh
okay
there was a new story that I came across
that was I gotta get this bottle on the
shot it makes me looks like look like an
alcoholic its water in that for the
record but I came across this and I had
completely forgotten the fact that Apple
along with freaking everybody and their
dog is planning to launch their own
streaming service and first of all I
forgot that was happening and some
things are leaking out about the process
of it cuz theoretically is supposed to
launch an April if it launches at all
it's gonna be a disaster
so here's the thing first of all Apple
is apparently spending about a billion
dollars on content now that may sound
like a lot but that is a fraction of
what say Netflix or Amazon spend on
their original programming so they're
spending way less money on the launch of
a streaming service so they're gonna
have not nearly as much content Plus
apparently they are micromanage hell
they airplane no I like the Apple
executives who don't work in
entertainment who are tech guys they're
beetle vacantly friendly I'm like guy
okay even aside from the amount of money
they're prepared to not spend on
launching this thing you you're not
going to attract any good talent with
that degree of restrictions I know you
got away with it with like the Apple App
Store but that's because you control the
platform
that is the iPhone you don't control
streaming platforms especially when
people already have alternatives the
iPhone is embedded because it was the
first and is still arguably one of the
best there's a bunch of great streaming
platforms already
you're not gonna entice good people to
make good stuff I and therefore know
it's gonna want this it's so weird to me
that how many of these companies are
launching these these things on their
own audio glitches ah god
hold on how bad is it hang on a my back
and my back am I gone so much lag it's
alright now do you mind if I ask a
personal question I don't go right ahead
it's not buffering now don't worry it
happened a little bit ago okay alright
seems like it's okay now and now I don't
mind if you ask a personal question any
specific things you're hoping to see an
Avengers end game uh just a good movie I
mean like really it's never I'm never
gonna have an interesting answer - do
you have specific things you want to see
an X thing that's coming out I just
wanted to be good like that's it I'm not
I'm never gonna have a good answer to
that kind of question you're in and out
every few minutes crap is there a biopic
you'd like to see made oh probably
I just don't know off the top of my head
but yeah I'm sure I'm sure there are a
few that I were to sit down and think
about I could come up with I am sitting
down you know what I mean
Avengers end Daleks have you seen the
100 I have not
if BBC were to have a slideshow about a
campaign like the Sarah a sideshow about
it as I thought I said slideshow
sideshow about a companion like Sarah
Jane Adventures who would it be well I
mean I the Pater Noster gang is the
obvious go-to for that and I was
actually kind of surprised that they did
the whole class thing instead of having
that speaking of streaming services
brick boxes every Doctor Who episode
except reign of terror Crusades Ghazis
listening ones they don't have yep I
mean brick box is how I watch watch
classic who by and large I I don't think
they have the animated recreations
though I haven't checked I don't think
they're on there I assumed because with
the animation companies there's
additional licensing going on there or
did I just MIT or did I miss that
I Miss Sarah Jane spin-off I would like
to see other characters return well fair
enough
what's your favorite Doctor Who episode
favorite new who is heaven-sent favorite
classic is city of death what else
happened oh there was the new Hellboy
trailer came out not long after last
week's streaming streaming and it was a
heck of a lot better than the first one
was I still I'm still really hesitant
about the makeup I really feel like
David harbors getting lost in it and I
don't think that's him I think they they
have bulked out the face so much that in
he it just looks like a face in a wall
of makeup so I'm a little nervous about
that but the vibe was a heck of a lot
better it was really metal this is what
it was which is a distinct isn't is
works for Hellboy and is distinctly
different from what Yama Deltora did
with this sort of twisted fairy tale
vibe
so that was that was cool I'm excited
for that
I'm I'm hoping that movie works if that
if Hellboy is in line with that second
trailer I think it might be pretty good
unfortunately I worried that they
botched their first impression because
that first trailer was really bad and
you know given that this doesn't appear
to be getting a really heavy marketing
push missing that first impression might
end up hurting them quite a bit uh what
do you know what do you mean when you
say your daughter likes wolves I she
likes
wolves I mean I don't I guess I don't
know what's confusing about that
statement she thinks wolves are very
cool and cute she likes stories with
wolves she likes you know
educational books about wolves she like
she has stuffed animal wolves she likes
wolves that's kind of her thing any
cartoon from childhood you would like to
see in a movie version yes but I would
also want it to be an MIT there's
there's literally no animated thing that
I would rather see in live-action that
doesn't exist but in terms of something
from when I was younger coming back as a
movie gargoyles probably be at the top
of that list do you have a favorite
comedian if you're into British humor
check out Lee Evans I also recommend to
Ricky Gervais I can't stand Ricky
Gervais I really can't
I've never liked Ricky Gervais stand he
has popped up in things that I enjoy and
I skip his parts in them I skip his
scenes and Stardust and I skip his
episode in galavant I really can't stand
him and it's he's just so smug it's it's
similar to why I can't stand Bill Maher
I did ah but um in terms of favorite
comedians I mean it's really hard to top
George Carlin and even though some of
his stuff especially later on in his
life didn't always click for me he'd
probably still take the top spot for
many British comedians I mean Eddie
Izzard who I've actually gotten to see
perform live which was very cool did you
happen to catch umbr.ella Academy
haven't gotten past the first episode
not cuz I don't want to but because Liz
and I started it together we haven't had
the chance to continue it together so
that's that anything that the two of us
watched together as opposed to
separately is always something that we
are gonna get through slowly since today
okay that was that was a question for
somebody else
oh the hufflepuffs Hough across raven
puffs yeah have you seen the expanse I
have not do you like e RB I don't know
what that stands for I've mentioned this
before
don't use abbreviations with me cuz I
won't know what they mean like I can
almost never keep track of these things
favorite fruit um Anjou pears but they
need to be under ripe yeah the weirdly
specific isn't it
Doctor Who youtubers you'd like that
aren't friends of the channel um well I
can't remember who's listed as friends
of the channel off the top my head for
the comparative I mean I love I like the
Doctor Who guy who's on here and not
just cuz he's on the chat right now
although that is cool um I like crispy
Pro I like stew bankfull obviously I
like wingy even though I know he's
taking a break
I like case creeper yeah I mean I'd I
enjoy all these all these fellow all
these folks
almost all these guys I'm really trying
to get out of the habit of using guys as
my goat
to plural for a group of people but but
in my head guys is a gender-neutral term
I'm still trying to get out of the habit
though and I tend to stumble over it
let's see what else did I have Oh
so here's another thing that was a news
story I came across them was like wait
that's a thing that's even happening uh
from Reno um and that is apparently
Sherlock Holmes three with Robert Downey
jr. and Jude Law has been delayed until
December of 22:21 and another new does
apparently they're doing a sherlock
holmes 3 okay I guess they waited for
Sherlock
okay I guess they waited for Sherlock to
finish up so that they didn't feel
totally irrelevant I don't know I
actually did like those movies that they
weren't I mean they didn't nail all the
elements but mo most um Sherlock Holmes
adaptations tend to get at least one
thing right one element right there's
almost none of them when they get
everything right like some get the
mystery really well some get Sherlock
specifically there's a character really
well some get a really good Watson some
getting the dynamic between the two
really well some nail the setting
there's very few that nail everything
and the the Robert Downey jr. and the
Jude Law Sherlock Holmes the dynamic
between those two was great they were
awesome loved them the rest that was
going on around him I mean Rachel
McAdams was out of her depth the
mysteries were okay the Moriya their
take on Moriarty was decent but it was
really those two when the whenever it
wasn't those two together the the movie
became the movies became less
interesting do you have any pets I
personally do not my daughter as a
hamster but I don't I don't have any
pets at at present I don't really have
the time to take care of pets is is my
problem
Elementary was better than Sherlock by
far I don't I don't know if Elementary
got better I think I gave I was I don't
know I was maybe eight nine episodes in
to the first season excuse me God uh the
first season of elementary when I bowed
out and it wasn't because it was bad it
was because I'd seen wait two men the
parol crying out for bill on the
patterns too well
so while I did like that Sherlock and
that Watson I found myself figuring out
the mysteries really really quickly
because they fit the standard police
procedural template and I've just seen
way too many of them that I just don't
get engaged by that anymore
even when it's done well it's the same
reason I gave up on Castle after a while
any directors you can't stand um I'm not
sure that I put it that would like the
reason I I'm that emphatic about
somebody like Ricky Gervais is that it
is his personality that really grates me
more than anything else whereas very few
directors are that public like with what
their personality even is so I don't
think in a if you're sort of going off
of how in that eclis height I don't like
Ricky Gervais and sort of applying it to
directors not really I mean there is
there are directors who works I just
don't get you know Kubrick sorry but you
know not really any that I that I would
say I can't stand not I'll stop my head
at any rate uh I recommend a show that's
quite different than what Dan lost it
hang on
backing up uh I recommend a show that's
quite different than what you usually
watch it's a dramedy called Jane the
Virgin oh I've heard of that one um oh
shoot
did I stall again crap
thoughts on Spielberg's beef with
Netflix I he's overdoing it he's
starting to I I get some of what he's
saying but he's really starting to come
across in a get off my lawn kind of way
I don't like it cuz it's new I mean I
think the one thing he has a point about
is as far as the Oscars go specifically
like if you want to say that all the
films need to be playing by the same
rules to qualify for that award you know
what fair enough but with the whole
general vibe of his attack on it and his
basically saying these are TV movies
like no dude no they streaming movies
are just as capable of being as good as
anything that's put out in theater your
venue does not determine your worth for
a piece of art so yeah I'm not I'm not
out on board with him on that same
here's with guys and dude Buffy the
Vampire Slayer versus Doctor Who which
is well the correct answer is it depends
on what you like if you're asking me
Doctor Who is better but it's also not
fair because I can cherry-pick over 50
years worth of artha off and genero it
down to the to the best stuff whereas
buffy was seven years and done and it's
like it's really hard to compare almost
any show to Doctor Who for that reason
alone the good place ugly I mean go come
back I did I did a review on season
three when it ended love to go places
terrific
I've got a video called why the good
place is awesome yeah watch it currently
watching WWE scooby-doo movie oh boy
how's that I'm curious
see what did I have on my end it's
looking like it's buffering is it still
okay for you for you folks just checking
have you thought about encouraging your
daughter to read the wolf brothers
novels I've never heard of them so no
they're about a cave boy in his wolf cub
companion I might look into that
functioning yes it's fine buffers now
and then it buffers every few minutes
it's good for me right now dang it man
tonight's just all over the place that's
annoying I don't want to have to restart
it it's still buffering you know what I
am though
so Will Smith is out of suicide squad
yeah yeah I saw that
um which you know I I don't know what to
think about the fact that there even is
a suicide squad okay I am actually gonna
go ahead and restart this because it's
buffering for me and it sounds like it's
buffering off and on for other folks too
so I'm gonna stop this